[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live lord cognito
here i
love podcast lords of gaming.net with
the amazing lord jonah
from whale food thank you thank you sir
going pretty well
no doubt no doubt pandemic but we're
we're
here
like first convention a long time so
it's great to finally like
be with people again bro you have no
idea
we'll deal with this to talk games
exactly so let's get to it first of all
we were here 2019. it was this little
game
that came across our radar and me and
the rest of the lords are playing a
very competitive game of kung fu
kickball so tell us for the realm who
don't know for people who don't know
about this game
what is kung fu so kung fu kickball is a
team-based fighting sports game where
the best ball kicker wins
you gotta punch kick and head butt your
way across the field to smash the ball
into your opponent's goal and rack up
points
nice nice thing so what i remember
they were like you could perform
fighting moves
in the game you can actually hit the
other characters also right
that's right you can hit the other
characters but there's no like health
bars or anything you can't like kill
another character right
just kind of knock it out temporarily so
you can get them out of the way and kick
that ball so it's like
it's like kickball a little rugby little
physical actor
or like the movie shaolin soccer if you
ever see that one that's a great one
okay i got it i like the challenge all
right cool so now that again it's been
out
and as far as the platform that is it
exists currently
what can you tell us about that uh so
right now it's out on steam early access
uh you know been testing out the netcode
and stuff so we wanted to make sure that
was solid before we did the
the full release but then later this
year it's coming out to
all the consoles switch xbox ps4
and you know it'll all work on ps5 as
well and all that you get you get them
excited now
because we've been waiting my console
friends they saw what fun we were having
it was crazy it was competitive it was
crazy so we cannot wait so later this
year
later this year and we're talking switch
we're talking xbox playstation oh man we
cannot wait
now since then what have you learned
since that time from from what we saw in
2019 to now
uh let's see i've learned that code is
really hard
it ain't that easy huh i mean i can't
already do that but i learned
that yeah it's really hard no doubt um
what else have you learned let's see
what else have i learned
um i guess i
just learned to keep going you know
games take a while
i think i now i've been working on this
game for almost four years
now as far as the team it's solely you
it's just it
uh you have all the other people as part
of the wealthful like
what you guys consist of as a team so
whale food is just me
okay um you know i do other people have
worked on the game i hired art
contractors and stuff to actually make
it look good
um and then i have a publisher blowfish
games
so they're helping with bringing it to
console nice and you know
some porting work and stuff like that um
but most of it is 100
me dude that's awesome and first of all
it's very inspiring because being like
one developer you know having this
passion
seeing it through it can't be easy so
every time
i personally see you guys i get excited
because of you the dream is still going
the vision's still happening he's always
got great energy when he comes out here
we had to support kung fu kickball so
that's number one
and number two like i said we just
cannot wait for it to leave people don't
realize how fun
this game is it is a ton of fun and also
i'm gonna ask you about switch because
i think it's really suited to that
audience you know i'm saying so as far
as um
there's going to be an online component
obviously with the netcode and what
about anything in the cooperative space
like um multiple switches and stuff like
that can you play it that way or
not or is it just online for now you
know
i'm i think i'm not sure actually okay
um
i don't know if that's like a separate
thing from the switch online or whether
that kind of
integrates i would hope it would work
with multiple switches um
yes i know we will find out as we get
there
so anyway for people who want to learn
more about the game try to get as much
information where can they go
what could you tell them so they can go
to kung fukickball.com
uh there you can like sign up for the
mailing list to be notified when it's
out on console
you also reach me on twitter at
and then we also have a discord if you
want to follow along with the game
discord
gg uh kung fu kickball nice you already
heard here the legendary
jonah wilford games this is an honor to
see him again
we're getting closer for those who are
interested kung fu kickful
is an amazing fun game you can beat the
hell out of each other and just
it's still small to go but look it is an
honor and always
always brother good to see you you
already heard it here laura cognito
highland podcast loyaltygaming.net
you